well many here in las vegas are sending
the reactions
uh to the verdict joining us now to talk
about it is
the president of our local naacp chapter
roxanne mccoy thank you so much for
joining us here today
first off let me ask you first give us
your reaction
to the verdict my reaction to the
verdict is kind of mixed
i am excited to know that they did find
mr shovin guilty of murdering
george floyd but you know everybody is
celebrating right now
but then we have so many lives that have
been lost before us
that we didn't get a guilty bird of dawn
so my emotions are a little mixed
right now even though i'm happy that the
jury did make the right decision on this
one
yes so many emotions going through
people right now now george floyd's
death caused a national reflection on
police reform including right here in
las vegas
tell us about the work you think still
needs to be done right here in southern
nevada if any on police accountability
and on police reform well i think that
we need to go back to
our nevada statutes revise statues
and look at the laws that we have on the
books here because the reason why derek
shoving was able to be convicted is
because
of the laws that they have on the books
there in their state
but we need to make sure that the laws
in our state
state that if an officer kills
an unarmed black man or unarmed person
period
that they can be convicted of murder
and not oppression under the color of
law
so i'm not really sure what exactly
those laws look like
we need to take a look at those and see
what those are looking like to make sure
that we have accountability here in the
state in which we reside
all right roxanne thank you so much for
your time we deeply appreciate your
input now stay with us
on 8 news now we'll be right back